gabe kling tp alors ce nom va sûrement
rien vous dire et pourtant c'est la plus
vieille construction mégalithique de la
planète c'est un édifice qu'on trouve au
sud de la turquie et c'est bourré de
mystère par exemple pourquoi il ya ce
géant de pied arqué ici c'est quoi les
gravures qui sont réalisés dessus
c'était quoi une utilité de ce site
kaleme exceptionnelles pour répondre à
toutes ces interrogations je suis jamais
tout celle d'un comité curieuse souhaite
avec thomas laurent qui va parrainer ce
quatrième épisode dans suis très heureux
bonjour les amis je suis très content de
vous retrouver dans cet épisode de
cabine et curieuse aujourd'hui on part à
la découverte d'un site archéologique
fascinant alors direction la turquie
avec fabien bienvenue d'un cabinet
curieux
[Musique]
il est perché et pas thomas laurent
guillet bien mon mégalithes à 750 mètres
d'altitude il s'étend sur 300 mètres de
diamètre et surtout il fait l'objet de
beaucoup de mystères à son sommet on
peut même apercevoir les montagnes
syrienne ce site a été découvert en 1960
et c'est seulement à partir des années
1990 qu'ils ont commencé à faire des
fouilles sur le site alors avant de
parler de ce qu'ils ont trouvé et des
hypothèses de à quoi ça servait tout ça
avant de soulever toutes ces pierres
c'est parce qu'on va parler piercy un
moment donné enfin pas d'un pote qui
s'appelle pierre avant de parler de tout
ça il faudrait voir de quoi est composé
ce site thomas est ce que tu peux nous
renseigner là dessus ce qui va nous
intéresser c'est la couche la plus
profonde et la plus ancienne que les
archéologues ont baptisé couche numéro
trois dans cette couche on a retrouvé
des sortes d'enceinte circulaire parsemé
de monolith les monolithes les plus
impressionnants sont situés au centre
des enceintes ils sont toujours par deux
et il mesure à peu près 5 mètres de haut
hors éléments tout à fait intéressant à
propos de ces monolithes ils
reproduisent des silhouettes humaines et
oui ça peut sembler bizarre mais c'est
confirmé puisque on a effectivement des
représentations de bras demain et de
ceinture sur ses piliers ces piliers qui
reproduisent des silhouettes humaines
sont d'ailleurs pratiquement les seules
représentations humaines de l'ensemble
du site alors oui effectivement un
personnage sans tête ou encore
d'étranges oiseaux avec des jambes
humaine mais globalement les
représentations sont surtout des animaux
sauvages et vautours des sangliers des
gazelles etc on verra tout à l'heure ce
que ça peut signifier mais d'abord
première grande question de quand sadate
et bien tout ça a été construit il ya
onze mille ans
onze mille ans ça veut dire plus de 6000
en avance ce même jeu ou encore avant la
pyramide de khéops avec deux béquilles
tp on est vraiment à la préhistoire à la
préhistoire effectivement mais dans un
contexte un peu particulier puisqu'on
est dans le croissant fertile au moment
où apparaît l'aviculture et ça
c'est important d'en parler de minutes
contrairement à ce qu'on peut imaginer
l'apparition de l'agriculture est un
phénomène extrêmement long ça prend
vraiment des siècles et a gobé cli tp on
est à une étape de ce processus une
étape très intéressante imaginez bien
les gens qui ont construit que bic
l'istp sont des chasseurs cueilleurs
comme leurs lointains ancêtres mais par
contre ça fait déjà des générations
qu'ils ne sont plus nomades ce sont des
gens qui habitent dans des villages dans
des maisons ajoutez à ça que ces gens
ont probablement commencé déjà à semer
récolter des céréales sauvage puisqu'on
est à l'époque où apparaît l'agriculture
près domestique et ce milan avant que
les gens deviennent de véritables
aviculteurs on est donc face à des
chasseurs cueilleurs qui sont dans des
villages et qui pratique une forme
d'agriculture près domestique à côté de
la chasse et de la cueillette vous voyez
la situation est assez complexe et bien
évidemment c'est cette complexité qui
rendent des clips et si passionnant
alors puisque le décor est planté on
peut passer à la grande question à quoi
servez ce site si milan avant stone age
c'est énorme on avait fait une vidéo un
cabinet curieuse sur stone elle je vous
invite à le regarder là on est six mille
ans avant mais il ya quelque chose
d'assez curieux c'est qu'à l'intérieur
ces enclos on trouve pas de trace de
deux foyers d'objets du quotidien comme
des bols des fourchettes des iphone tout
ce qu'ils avaient à l'époque quoi ça
veut dire qu'on est sûr d'une chose ce
n'était pas des maisons et si c'était
pas des maisons la question se pose à
quoi servaient ces monuments et bien là
il ya deux grandes hypothèses majeur qui
s'offre à nous la première il s'agirait
peut-être deux temples et c'est fou
parce que ce serait les plus les
premiers temples de l'humanité c'est une
thèse qui a été défendu par
l'archéologue klaus schmidt selon lui
c'est un grand sanctuaire régional qui a
tiré d'un peu partout sûrement dans la
région depuis des dizaines de kilomètres
des personnes qui viendraient se
recueillir donc les constructions
mégalithique aurait abrité des pratiques
rituelles parmi lesquels le chamanisme
ne sais pas pourquoi je l'annoncé comme
ça
l'idée du chamanisme c'est pas
inintéressant on peut facilement les
imaginer sur place en train de danser et
faire la femme de prendre de la drogue
avec les adeptes qui sont à moitié en
transe le chaman lui qui s'élève vers un
monde spirituel et surnaturel et
d'ailleurs pour les défendeurs de cette
thèse là les représentations des
vautours et des sangliers ça confirme au
rsa parce que ce serait les esprits qui
serait représenté et quant au corps
d'oiseau avec des jambes d'humains ce
serait la représentation des chamans
entrant en train de se transformer pour
justement aller parler aux esprits s'ils
ont une indian à côté du chamanisme
klaus schmidt a émis une autre hypothèse
qui est tout aussi intéressante c'est
celle du totémisme alors attention je ne
dis pas que les personnes là-bas de pub
qui tp chercher de totem d'immunité
c'est pas le projet mais selon klaus les
différents bâtisseurs de gately tp
aurait peut-être appartenu à différents
clans et chaque clan aurait été
représentée par un totem ignoring par
exemple le clan du sanglier le clan du
vautour le clan des cathédrales le monde
est entré dans un nouveau millénaire si
vous l'avez celle là vous êtes vraiment
chaud évidemment le totémisme et le
chamanisme ça peut fonctionner ensemble
c'est pas incompatibles alors peut-être
que les deux pistes au final elles sont
vraies pour gober clic par contre
aujourd'hui on n'écarte complètement la
piste des temples c'est pas possible
concrètement un temple évidemment ça
devait être consacrée à des lieux et là
bas y'a rien qui indique qu'ils avaient
des dieux qui était vénéré alors
peut-être que les grands piliers avec
les bras sur les côtés sont des ancêtres
mais attention ni la présence du
surnaturel mis les rituels n'en font des
tempes vous commencez à le sentir
guvecli tp c'est pas un site très
évident c'est plutôt compliqué on sent
qu'il ya plein de mystères et tout ça
d'ailleurs on a mis en évidence
récemment d'autres types de rituels qui
a été fait sur place et ça c'est pas moi
qui vais vous en parler c'est thomas
parce que moi en fait je sais pas j'ai
pas réviser cette partie
thomas ce qu'on ne vous a pas encore dit
c'est que les différents enclos ont été
artificiellement enterrait autrement dit
les chasseurs cueilleurs ont préféré les
reboucher avec des tonnes de terre ce
qui a demandé des efforts colossaux
plutôt que de les détruire ce qui nous
montre que même l'abandon de ces
bâtiments étaient très ritualisé
maintenant ce qui va nous intéresser
c'est ce qu'il y avait alain térieur de
ces rebouchage puisque en fouillant la
terre en dégageant ces enclos les
archéologues ont retrouvé deux types de
mobilier archéologique très intéressant
déjà on a retrouvé beaucoup d'ossements
animaux ce qui montre que de grand
festin était organisé autour des
monuments alors on peut imaginer des
chasses collective pourquoi pas mais on
peut aussi imaginer des grands festins
qui était donnée lors des campagnes de
construction justement pour mobiliser
les dizaines de bâtisseur c'est tout à
fait possible pour contre carte n'est
qu'ils avaient de grands festins et à
côté de ces aux animaux on a aussi
retrouvé des os humains alors attention
pas de cannibalisme à l'horizon sachez
que les zoos humains étaient très rares
et qu'il s'agissait surtout de morceaux
de crâne plus précisément des crânes à
décorer et suspendu des crânes décoré et
suspendu ça peut paraître un peu étrange
mais ça laisse la porte ouverte à deux
hypothèses la première piste qui est
soutenu par la majorité des archéologues
c'est celle d'un culte des ancêtres donc
très concrètement les crânes aurait
appartenu à des ancêtres élevé au rang
d'esprit et auquel on pouvait s'adresser
la seconde piste par contre à laquelle
je me rattache personnellement a été
développé par l'anthropologue alain
testart et pour lui ce ne sont
probablement pas des crânes d'ancêtres
mais plutôt des crânes trophée autrement
dit des têtes coupées prélevés sur des
ennemis vaincus alors c'est tout à fait
compatible avec des crânes décor est
même si ça peut paraître surprenant
puisqu'on connaît les sociétés qui vont
jusqu'à sur modeler les crânes des
ennemis vaincus donc cette hypothèse est
tout à fait plausible l'idée de trophées
c'est pas stupide ça pourrait même
peut-être expliquer la gravure de
l'homme sans tête selon alain testart il
s'agirait sûrement d'un ennemi corps
était vaincu dont on aurait pris la tête
et qu'on aurait livré aux charognards
klaus speed par contre avait une vision
qu'avaient rien à voir pour lui c'était
plutôt un rituel de funérailles où on
donnait comme sales et les morts aux
vautours en type en pâture alors c'est
pas idiot s'est glissée dans ce type de
funérailles par exemple les tour du
silence des zoroastriens beaucoup de
mots compliqués alors je fais gaffe à
comment je le prononce ou à l'époque on
exposait les morts pour que les vautours
et de manger comme ça alors
effectivement on a retrouvé des hausses
de charognards sur le site mais on n'a
rien retrouvé
concernant des cadavres humains quoi
comment il va mon à soulever des crèmes
gublis apparaît pile quand la
sédentarité et l'élevage commence à se
développer mentalités changent leur
société dans évolution le mot même
société n'existe pas avant ce moment là
on commence à construire des choses
qu'on n'a jamais construit auparavant
parce qu'on va plus bouger donc on peut
se sédentariser réellement aussi dans
ses constructions et ce qui est
absolument magique c'est qu'aujourd'hui
encore notre vision du site continue à
évoluer et à l'est par exemple et encore
20 ans à peine on était persuadé que le
site était isolé comme une sorte de
sanctuaire perdu dans la montagne mais
aujourd'hui on questionne la présence
d'un village et oui il y à des maisons
autour des enclos et certaines de ces
maisons appartiennent clairement à la
couche numéro 3 donc pourquoi pas un
village autour de go back l'istp autre
sujet de débat les enclos n'était pas
forcément à ciel ouvert comme on les
voit aujourd'hui aussi pour un certain
nombre d'archéologues notamment français
ces constructions avait un toit ce qui
en ferait de véritables bâtiment
personnellement c'est l'hypothèse qui me
semble clairement la plus plausible
j'imagine des bâtiments semi enterrés
avec un accès qui se faisait par le toit
et enfin cerise sur le gâteau sachez que
ces bâtiments n'ont peut-être pas tous
exister en même temps est tout à fait
possible qu'à chaque nouvel enclos
construit on rebouche elle précédent ce
qui veut dire qu'on aurait sous les yeux
non pas un espèce de grand complexe où
tout a existé en même temps mais plutôt
la succession de plone bâtiments qui
n'ont jamais été visible en même temps
qu'ils se sont succédé sur des siècles
et des siècles
vous voyez les questions à résoudre sont
encore nombreuses et il nous reste ma
foi beaucoup à comprendre sur ce site
moi j'espère vraiment que l'époux ils
vont permettre de lever si mystère qu'on
va en savoir plus en attendant j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plu merci
beaucoup à thomas laurent d'avoir
participé à cet épisode et je vous
invite à faire un tour sur sa chaîne
déjà parce que c'est très cool il parle
de mystères archéologiques avec une
bonne rigueur scientifique et pour les
plus patients d'entre vous il m'a dit
qu'il préparait une vidéo sur toute la
période qui entourent gublis que
boecklin tp ça a été dur à dire tout le
long de la vidéo je vous jure merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et merci
fabien pour l'invitation ça m'a fait
trop plaisir de participer je vous dis à
très bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
et puis comme on dit chez moi je veux
des schmutz à la prochaine chose
facile vous faites en tout cas merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé la vidéo vous
pouvez l'indiquer vous pouvez vous
abonner si vous connaissiez pas la
chaîne si vous voulez aller encore plus
loin j'ai un magazine papier sert
mensuel qui s'appelle cabinet curieuse
on est dans la troisième année on doit
être au numéro 26 déjà bref vous avez le
lien dans la description si vous voulez
découvrir un petit peu ce que c'est
c'est que sur abonnement vous cliquez
sur le lien dans la description et vous
pourrez lire des anciens articles voir
les anciens numéros voir si ça vous
plaît ou pas
autour de moi vous pouvez voir la
couverture et le sommaire du prochain
numéro et puis quoi d'autre loïc
on n'avait jamais entendu dans un
cabinet curieuse si moussa
[Musique]
c'est vrai
on m'a prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]
tous